السجال السياسي بين واشنطن وباكين مستمر
حتى بعد سقوط المنطاد الصيني ولا يتوقع اي
طرف ان ينتهي قريبا فاسئله عديده سالت
الان حول ما يمكن ايجاده داخل المنطاد وهل
فعلا هو منطاد تجسس كما تزعم الولايات
المتحده ام انه من تضم مدني لبحث الارصاد
الجويه كما تدعي الصين حاليا فان الترقب
يسود حول نتائج تحليل بقايا مكونات
المنطاد علما ان اجزاء منه قد تكون تعرضت
للتلف في المياه او للتفكك بسبب تاثير
ضربه الصاروخ الامريكي الذي استخدم
لاسقاطه بقايا المنطاد من المفترض ان ترسل
الى مختبر مكتب التحقيقات الفيدراليه
بولايه فيرجينيا حيث سيتكفل بتحليله خبراء
في وكالات الاستخبارات
وبحسب اولى المعلومات التي عرضها
البانتاجون فان المنطاد يحمل اجهزه
استشعار ومعدات مراقبه ويمكنه بذلك القيام
بعده مناورات وقد اظهر انه يمكن ان يغير
مساره حسين الطاوود معه المزيد من
التفاصيل
تاخر اسقاط الصيني حتى يوم السبت اثار
الكثير من الجدل الديمقراطيون يرون ان
الاداره الامريكيه وزاره الدفاع تصرفتها
بطريقه صحيحه بانتظاره حتى يصبح فوق
المحيط الاطلسي واسقطوه كي لا يتسبب بوقوع
اصابات بين المواطنين في المقابل يرى
الجمهوريون بان تاخر اداره الرئيس بايدن
باسقاط المنطاد ترك له حريه التحليق فوق
الولايات المتحده وجمع المعلومات وتعريض
امن البلاد للخطر واعتبروا التاخير عرضا
محرجا للضعف وفشلا للامن القومي
واذا سلمنا فعلا بان هذا المنطاد كان غرضه
التجسس كما تقول واشنطن فلا يزال السؤال
الاهم قائما ما سبب لجوء الصين الى هذه
الوسيله للتجسس في عصر الاقمار الصناعيه
هناك معطيات تبرر استخدام منطاد للتجسس
قياسا بالمميزات التي يتوفر عليها والتي
تغيب عن الاجهزه الحديثه الاخرى بهذا
الخصوص يقول وليمكم المتخصص في مناطيد
المراقبه في مركز ابحاث ماراثون في واشنطن
ان المنطاد قد يتوفر على ادوات تشتغل
بالذكاء الاصطناعي وهي احيانا تكون ادوات
متطوره قادره على رصد اهداف النوعيه وعلى
العكس من الاقمار الصناعيه المعرضه بشكل
متزايد للهجمات الارضيه والفضائيه فان
المناطيد تتمتع بقدرتها على التخفي من
الرادار لانها مصنوعه من مواد غير معدنيه
لا تعكس الضوء
ودائما اذا ما افترضنا ان المنطاد كان
للتجسس فما الذي كانت تسعى اليه الصين
تقول صحيفه واشنطن بوست بهذا الخصوص ان
المنطاد ربما استخدم لاختبار قدره امريكا
على اكتشاف التهديدات القادمه وايجاد
ثغرات في نظام انذار الدفاع الجوي للبلاد
كما قد يسمح ايضا المنطاد للصينيين
باستشعار الانبعاثات الكهرومغناطيسيه التي
لا تستطيع الاقمار الصناعيه عاليه
الارتفاع ان تكتشفها كالترددات اللاسلكيه
منخفضه الطاقه التي يمكن ان تساعدهم في
فهم كيفيه التواصل بين انظمه الاسلحه
الامريكيه المختلفه
توقيت الحادث ايضا قد يطرح علامات استفهام
عديده فقد اتى قبل ايام من زياره مرتقبه
لوزير الخارجيه الامريكي انتوني بلينكن
الى الصين هذه الزياره ارجعت بالطبع بعد
الحادث وهنا يطرح احتمال ان يكون الحادث
مقصودا لان رصد البالون الصيني في الاجواء
الامريكيه
وتعقبه واسقاطه كان كل ذلك متوقعا وهو ما
تعلمه بكين بالتاكيد بهذا الخصوص تحدثت
صحيفه الدارديان البريطانيه عن وجود
انقسام انقساما داخلي في مركز القرار في
الصين وبان هناك جهه تتخذ قرارات دون علم
جهات الاخرى داخل السلطه المركزيه الصينيه
ما يعزز هذه الاطروحه هو ان الحادثه نسفت
محاولات تهدئه التوتر بين امريكا والصين
علما ان الرئيس الصيني
كان ابدى
نيه في تحسين العلاقات وليس العكس من خلال
ترحيبه بزياره بلنكن التي لم تتم وفيما
يتعلق بردود فعل الطرفين فقد وصفت وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه اقتحام من طرد
المراقبه المجال الجوي الامريكي بانه غير
مقبول وغير مسؤول على الطرف الاخر فان
المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الصينيه اعرب
عن احتجاج بلاده الشديد على قيام الولايات
المتحده باسقاط منقادها المدني بدون طيار
مضيفا ان بكين تحتفظ بالحق في استخدام
الوسائل الضروريه للتعامل مع مواقف مماثله
وفي تطور اخر اعلنت السلطات الصينيه اقاله
رئيس هيئه الارصاد الجويه حيث حملته
المسؤوليه مسؤوليه انحراف المنطاد الى
امريكا قد تكون هذه مناوره صينيه لحرف
الانظار عن حقيقه المنطاد وقد لا تكون